but the latest data for you now from the
Department of Health on the number of
people in the UK who have lost their
lives in hospital after testing positive
with coronavirus and that total now
stands at fifteen thousand four hundred
and sixty-four that represents a further
eight hundred and eighty-eight people
there so we can speak now to our
correspondent Ali Fortescue who joins us
now from the newsroom Ali sometimes the
data that comes to us at the weekends
can can look a little out of kilter
can't it with with what we get during
the week but a very sobering moment to
reflect on the fact that nearly fifteen
and a half thousand people have lost
their lives now in UK hospitals yes
that's right sometimes on the weekend
the data can be slightly less than it is
in the week because of differences in
the way it's collected actually today it
is slightly more than the number
yesterday so let me just bring you those
figures that we've just had in the last
few moments so 888 more deaths that's
across the whole of the UK yesterday
that figure was 847 and that now brings
the total to fifteen thousand four
hundred and sixty-four we've also just
in the last few moments had the figures
for Scotland which is 56 more deaths
slightly less than yesterday when the
figure was 58 and that brings the total
there to 893 so those figures in the
last few moments we are expecting are
the figures of course from Wales and
Northern Ireland as well shortly I think
it's hard to draw any real long-term
conclusions from these day to day
numbers numbers do go up and down
slightly we're trying to look at the
longer-term trends and that figure has
gone up to slightly since yesterday
the 888 figure but I think it is still
consistent with the longer-term trend
that we're seeing and that's pilato
beginning to stop we are starting to see
the figures flattening and if you look
at that grow
you can see at the start of this month
it was taking about two days for the
numbers to double on Sunday we passed
that a grim milestone of 10,000 deaths
we have now passed the milestone of
15,000 deaths extensors it's looks like
that rate has slowed quite significantly
and now the numbers are doubling every
10 or so days so the rate is is slowing
somewhat but still we're talking about
hundreds of deaths every single day
something that a few months ago would
have been completely unimaginable and we
cannot lose sight of that
absolutely okay Ally thank you